جدل يحتضم في اسرائيل بشان ما نشرته
القناه الثانيه عشره الاسرائيليه وزعمت له
ضمن اتفاق التلافيا بين حزب اليكود واتحاد
المتزامتين الغربيين هدى هترى للمشاركه في
الائتلاف الحكومي لبنيامينه حسب القناه
الاسرائيليه فين الاتفاق يتضمن مطالب بعدم
انتاج الكهرباء في ايام السبت وزياده عدد
الشواطئ التي يتم فيها الفصل بين الرجال
والنساء كما شملت تمويل الحكومه لمراسم
دفن كتب التوراه المتهالكه التي يحرمنا
حرقها باي طرق اخرى اضافه الى زياده عدد
المتزنتين في الشركات الحكوميه اراد
اللكود ان يحسم الجدل ويتم من المواطنين
الاسرائيليين ووصف هذه البنود بانها مجرد
ما الطالبه وليست اتفاق وقال ان اي اتفاق
يبرم سيحافظ على الوضع القائم في البلاد
منذ سنين في خريطه احزاب اقصى اليمين التي
تحالف معها نتنياهو من اجل العوده الى
الحكومه نجد حزب هدى ترى او التوراه
اليهوديه الموحده الذي لا في الكنيست
ثمانيه مقاعد وهو حزب يميني ديني سياسي
متشدد تاسس عام
1992 يدعو الى اقامه دوله يهوديه تحكم
القوانين الدينيه ويرفض التفاوض مع
الفلسطينيين والى جانبه حزب شاس الديني
الشرقي المتشدد الذي نالت اثني عشر مقعدا
في الانتخابات الاخيره يمثل هذا الحزب
الشريحه المتدينه اليهوديه من اصول شرقيه
في اسرائيل
وتتباين مواقفه السياسيه فهو يريد التفاوض
مع الفلسطينيين لكن مواقفه متصلبه في
القضايا التفاضيه اما تحالف الصهيونيه
الدينيه الذي يتزحمه اليمني المتشدد كثير
فلديه 14 مقعدا في الكنيست يعد امتدادا
لحزب كاخ ومنظمه غشم وكان حزبك معروفا
بايديولوجيته القائمه على التوراه والعنف
المسلح لتحقيق امال الصهيونيه وحتى
اسرائيل صنفته منظمه الارهابيه عام
ورغم هذا الرصيد التاريخي الحاصل بالتطرف
يحاول نتنياهو الخروج من هذه الدائره
بتاكيده ان اسرائيل لن تتحول الى دوله
اصوليه وستبقى دوله تهتم بكل مواطنها دون
اي خروج عن القاعده